So that's all of the things that the keyword this doesn't refer to.
What is it that the keyword this will refer to?
Going back to our example of calling a function,
we notice that there's a dot to the left of this example.
When you notice a dot to the left of a function invocation,
meaning it was looked up as a property of an object,
you can look to the left of that dot and see what object it was looked up upon.
The object that a function is looked up upon when it's being invoked,
that object is what the keyword, this, will be bound to.
I'm giving you an approximate definition that is useful to get you out of 90%
of situations, because of course,
it may not be the case we use a dot to access this function.
We may, for example, use brackets.
And of course, in this example, it's also the case that,
that object to the left of the dot is the very same one that it
was defined originally to be a property of.
The fact that it's defined up here is a coincidence.
We could just as easily have called that same function as a property of
a different object provided it's stored as a method of that
second object as well.
In any case, it's not true that the object you
find a given function stored within will be what the keyword this refers to, nor
is it the case that an object, a function,
was originally defined with is going to be what the keyword this refers to.
In fact, it has everything to do with that call time dot and
the object that we find to the left of it.